foreign
let's kick off this hour with our friend
Matthew Cross across the line there over
in Canada Yonder ways Matthew Cross
across the line
across the line across the country
there's no Pond there so I had to say
line I didn't know how to say it Matthew
welcome to the show I'm sorry that I
exist
Hi how are you guys we're doing well how
can we help today
okay so before I ask my question there's
a bit of context that I got to give so
I'm 16 years old I work full-time and I
do that on a part-time schedule so I'm
doing 12 to 13 hours a day uh three to
four days a week because I'm still in
school full-time oh so by part-time you
just mean you're not doing this five
days a week
yeah yeah exactly I was like what kind
of Life Hack is this you're working
full-time part-time
yeah but I got it um but anyway I paid
for most of my own stuff I bought my own
car I pay for my insurance my gas my
phone plan a lot of my own food even
especially on the days where I'm working
and on top of this my parents have
decided that it's fair uh to charge 15
of my income as a rent or tax or
uh whatever you want to call it now you
guys are smarter than me you don't have
anything in in this so I'd like to know
whether or not you think that's fair or
I'm just overreacting and thinking that
it isn't
so how much do they want to charge you
uh it's 15 of my income so this month
it'll be close to five hundred dollars
and you're you're 16.
16.
I don't know what the laws are in Canada
but I don't think in America you would
have legal standing to charge a minor
rent
I don't think it is legal but
you know what's what's the motive behind
it have you just had a conversation with
them and say hey what's what's going on
here why all of a sudden do you want
rent money like are they broke do they
need money no no
it's kids it's kind of interesting
because for my dad he says it is about
the money he says it's not fair that he
should be the only person to like
provide for the family when he has
working children right
um
hold on
you're here because of him
you didn't ask to be here he brought you
into the world
yeah that's you should tell him Josh you
say well well well if it isn't
the consequences of your actions dad
the reason he
says when he was a kid he had to pay 50
of his income right and he probably had
to walk up and down uphill nude in the
snow to school both ways like whatever
like he could grieve okay um and then
then there's my mother she she has a
slightly different side she doesn't
think that um it's about the money it's
about well according to her
real life there's rent there's expenses
and whatnot and this is real life so
this is what we're teaching you all
right so let me let me push back on that
on that for our general audience
um there was a great Camp right Camp was
a name for uh a mixed martial arts
school
um called shoot a box out of Brazil and
they had some of the greatest fighters
in the world
um vandely Silva was out of there Shogun
who was that I mean it was just the
Who's Who and they were known for having
practices where they just beat the tar
out of each other they would do really
intense workouts they'd do really
intense
um physical training but they would just
fight every day and they were known for
being the most intense fighters in the
ring maniacal like they would win fights
before they even got in there and I
never missed a Shogun fight and never
missed a vandalized silver fight I never
miss shoebox shoebox fights because they
were so I mean they were so entertaining
to watch they were just insane and
those guys career was significantly
curtailed
because the idea was you're gonna get
hit in the ring so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna hit you a bunch before
you get in the ring
and that's gonna make you better in the
ring and that works for a very short
window of time
until all that cumulative damage makes
you where you can't even climb up in the
ring anymore and now 15 20 years later
almost all of the gyms have very limited
full-on contact sparring
they saved the hits for the gym and so I
am sick of parents saying well I'm going
to hit you now because the world's gonna
hit you later as though that's gonna
help you later
what I want to do is give you a context
what love looks like and connectivity
looks like so in the world hits you in
the face you are anchored into something
way stronger and I'm not talking about
making soft weak kids I'm not it's not
it at all but we don't have to go all
the way over here where I'm gonna start
charging you right now because one day
it's going to charge you rent they're
going to show you how you clearly
Matthew
clearly
are light years ahead of people your own
age I don't know any 16 year olds who
are where you're at right now paying
cash for their cars covering their own
gas and insurance buying their own meals
so the right idea that you actually go
ahead I did actually borrow money from
my sister to buy my car but I I did pay
her off two days ago actually so good so
here's the other side of this there's
not a lot you can do
yeah that's fair and so
um here's where this breaks my heart is
the moment you turn 18 you're probably
gone
and they will have lost the relationship
and influence with their son and I hope
that it's not too late for them
foreign
but if I'm you I'm probably gonna wait
I'm gonna abide my time until I'm 18 and
then they won't ever see me again I'm
out of here
and I hate that for all of y'all because
I I it's just not healthy or good for
anybody but that's the world they're
creating
and I don't know that you have another
option unless you're gonna move out at
16 which I don't know that's a wise deal
too
um are you in high school right now
uh yeah I am I mean you're an impressive
kid I would just be proud if I was your
parents yeah but here's here's the deal
the other side of this is you go all
right I'll just stop working and what
happens then they have to cover all of
your bills plus they get zero dollars in
rent yeah what is that what sounds a lot
like the Canadian government which is
going to penalize you for the better you
do all right they're just gonna keep
penalizing you more and more what if you
said hey I really want to focus on
school Dad I'm not going to work anymore
and I now I need money to cover all
these bills
what would they say
uh they would just cut off everything
you wouldn't be you wouldn't have a car
anymore you wouldn't have a phone you
wouldn't have gas you'd get zero dollars
yes do you help out around the house
taking care of the house
I try to but not usually which is
another reason why they say they charge
it because
like like I said like I'm gone but when
the sun comes up to like everybody's in
bed when I get home because you're in
school and work and then working your
tail off
yeah exactly this whole thing just feels
arbitrary to me yeah so I'm gonna have a
few conversations with them to get to
the heart of what this really is about
because if it's just like I'm gonna
financially abuse you because that's
what my dad did and it made me the man I
am today that's just bad parenting it's
just to put that on yourself sorry man
I'm sorry
um I can't think of
they should be cheering you on until
they are hoarse and I'm sorry that
they're penalizing you for being a
go-getter and uh I hope this doesn't
ruin your relationship long term man
because y'all gonna need each other down
the road but I'm just heartbroken for
you my man absolutely but you're a minor
you live in their house
it's their rules